as I've told you many times SCTV that
show probably one of the main reasons
that I wanted to get into this business
you guys uh completely at the same time
that Saturday Night Live was on you guys
were doing sketch comedy I thought was
50 years ahead of its time you're
amazing you moderated our event that we
did at the Aspen Comedy Festival years
after it was in the 90s I think the 90s
and we because we filmed that show
without a live audience and we'd never
heard live laughter that was the first
time because they showed Clips behind us
it was the first time we really saw an
effect and you were so great it was
sweet to see you guys hearing you had
been working away in in Toronto in
Edmond Edmonton the bowels of ITV I
don't say bowels
uncomfortable who wants to hear about
the bowels of Edmonton uh but you guys
were working away and you never got to
hear the laughter and then we were
showing the the clips from the sketches
and just killing yeah the audience which
is so nice for you it was so touching
yeah you've written this book now did
you learn much about yourself writing
this book well I did learn not to take
myself too seriously that is for sure
right at the end I was finishing the
book and I was you know I'm just going
to spend the afternoon at a museum and I
went to the mocha um a Museum of
Contemporary Art and I'm their watch
looking at the art and I feel somebody
behind me staring at me and I'm thinking
you know can't a celebrity get a break
what is a Paparazzi around you all the
time why can't I have a good day like
any normal person and she tapped me on
the shoulder and she said excuse me are
you Cher's mother
the same
more depressing now this is interesting
the title lady Parts uh Steve Martin
came up with a who you're friends with
came up with a alternate title what was
his title that he wanted to go with and
why okay well he originally came up with
a I couldn't think of a title for the
book and we were at a dinner party at
his home and uh he said I have the title
and he yelled it out in front of eight
people perky tits he said
now I'm like really uncomfortable to say
that story of shares money
I suggested that
I think anybody had a reason for
suggesting that well okay we yes he did
well did you read Paul shaffer's
autobiography I did yeah where he had a
chapter well this is terrible to get
into but why not exactly we're amongst
friends don't let this out of the
audience all right you used to do you
alsoever talked about this in his book
and I've also heard it from other uh
SCTV cast members you have yes I have
you had a habit a while ago what was the
70s of flashing my boobs a little bit to
people and you would always say you
would walk up to people you didn't even
know and and and lift up your shirt
flashing yeah your breasts and so you've
seen these haven't you
in here I bet that was born in the 70s
was anybody alive in the 70s yeah who
flashed their boobs in the 70s hands wow
well Andy
Andy still does that yeah it was the 70s
it was it was you know when the moon is
in the seventh house yes well you guys
were all in the original and this cast
of here the next time then lift your
blouse
and show them off
you uh you were in that amazing cast of
oh God spell uh it's you and and Martin
Short and Gilda Radner and Victor Garber
was our Jesus Eugene Levy Paul Schaefer
was our musical director and so yeah
there you are so that was what you were
up to you were walking around in fact I
did other things yes I know you did you